- [Instructor] So what we have
are three different pictures
of substances undergoing
some type of change.
And we're going to focus on in this video
is classifying things as
either being physical changes
or chemical changes.
And you might already have already thought
about this or seen this in
a previous science class.
But when we talk about a physical change,
we're talking about where
there could be a change
in properties but we're
not having a change
in the actual composition
of what we're talking about,
while in a chemical change
you actually do have a change
in composition, how the
different constituent atoms
and elements match up or
connect or bond to each other
might be different.
So my first question to
you is pause this video
and we have some ice melting here.
We have some propane
combusting or burning here,
and we have some iron rusting here.
And I want you to think
about which of these are physical changes,
and which of these are
chemical changes and why.
All right, now let's first
think about this water,
this ice melting.
And if we wanted to write it
in fancy chemical language,
or chemistry language, we
could write this as H2O,
going from its solid form to
H2O going into its liquid form.
Now, we don't have a
change in composition,
in either state whether you're looking
at this liquid water here,
or whether you're looking
at the solid water there,
you'll see a bunch of water molecules.
Each oxygen is still
bonded to two hydrogens.
And so you're not having
a change in composition.
And so this over here is a
physical, physical change.
And if we kept heating that water up
and it started to vaporize
that would also be a physical change.
Whereas it turns into water vapor.
You have your intermolecular
forces being overcome
but the covalent bonds
between the oxygens and the hydrogens,
those aren't breaking
or forming in some way.
So once again, when you
go from ice to water,
physical change, from water to vapor
or you could say from liquid to gas
that is also going to
be a physical change.
One general rule of thumb
when you think about
what's going on on a microscopic level,
and this is a general rule of thumb.
It doesn't always apply.
And we'll think about an
edge case in a little bit
is when you're overcoming
intermolecular forces
that tends to be a physical change.
But if you have chemical
bonds forming or breaking
that would be a chemical change.
Now let's think about what's
going on here with the propane.
If you were to write the
chemical reaction here
it would be propane C3H8 in gas form.
It needs oxygen to combust.
So for every mole of propane
we have five moles of
molecular oxygen in gas form.
And then when it combusts
you're going to produce
three for every one mole
of propane and five moles
of molecular oxygen,
you're gonna produce three
moles of carbon dioxide gas
and four moles of water
in vapor form as well.
And so what you actually have is the bonds
in those molecules are actually breaking
and then re forming.
So you don't just have
physical change going on here.
You have chemical change, chemical change.
One way to think about it.
You had propane here before, C3 H8,
after the reaction you no
longer have the propane here.
When you actually see as
fire, which is fascinating.
This is just very hot gas,
and that very hot air that you're seeing,
and there's gonna be some
carbon dioxide in there
water vapor in there.
The reason why it's getting so hot
is because this releases a lot of energy.
Now let's think about what's
going on here with this iron.
If I were to write this
as a chemical reaction,
for every four moles of iron in solid form
plus three moles of
molecular oxygen in gas form,
and that would just be the
ambient oxygen around this iron.
It is going to produce two
moles of iron oxide as a solid
and that's what you see
there in the orange.
That is the iron oxide.
So notice this reaction
is forming new ionic bonds
in that ferrous oxide.
And to undergo the reaction we had to
break the metallic bonds of the solid iron
and the covalent bonds
in the molecular oxygen.
So anytime we are breaking and
making these chemical bonds
we have a chemical change.
Now, let me give you an
interesting question.
What about the dissolving of
sodium chloride or table salt?
So you have NaCl in its solid form,
when you place it into water,
you get sodium chloride in aqueous form.
And how does that look when this happens?
Well, sodium chloride in solid form,
you know it forms this lattice
because they have these ionic bonds.
I'll try to draw a few of them.
So it looks something like this,
where we've seen this multiple times,
chlorine nabs electrons becomes
chloride, becomes negative.
Sodium loses electron
becomes a positive ion.
And so they get attracted to each other
and then they can form this
three-dimensional lattice structure,
when it is in solid form.
And I'm trying my best to draw it
in three dimensions over here.
And actually I could put one
right over here like this,
but when you dissolve it into water
the ions get split apart.
You get the ions that all get dissolved,
they get split apart in the water.
And so the ionic bonds
themselves are being broken.
Now you could argue that, hey, you know
the constituent ions are
just being separated.
So maybe this is a physical change
or you could say, no, ionic bonds.
Those are legit bonds.
Those are strong bonds, and
those are getting broken.
And so you're also
getting chemical change.
And it actually turns out
that this is a gray area
when you're talking about
dissolving a salt like this
into water, whether you're
talking about a physical change
or you're talking about a chemical change.
And actually just this past
weekend, I was at the beach
and we ran out of salt
and I did this in reverse.
I went to the ocean and I
got a pot full of salt water.
And it actually took me
about 30 minutes to boil it.
And I was able to evaporate
all of the water out of it.
And essentially the salt
in that water was able
to reform these ionic bonds.
And so one could debate whether
I was creating a physical
or a chemical change.
I was definitely doing a
physical change with the water.
I was evaporating it, but I was
actually forming ionic bonds
between the sodium and chloride.
So one could argue that
that was maybe a physical
and a chemical change.